i'm larry goldstein i'm a professor of
cellular and molecular medicine at uc
san diego
and i'm pleased to be here interviewing
paul berg in a second segment about
paul's experiences
both originally in the
regulation of recombinant dna as you
heard in the previous segment and now i
want to move him along to discussions of
places where the original model of
recombinant dna has not worked as well
where the issues have perhaps been a
little more socially complicated paul
you'll remember as a nobel laureate
winner of the public policy award of the
american society for cell biology and in
some ways a role model that many of us
have sought to emulate in our dealings
with the body politic and the press and
everything else so paul thank you for
joining us again thank you
so so you know thinking about
acilamar and how acilamar and
recombinant dna regulation really set
the tone for scientists calling for
regulation and driving the kind of
regulation that has
in fact developed and been followed
i know that genetically modified foods
and the stem cell debates have not lent
themselves very well to that kind of
model
are there are there principles you think
or reasons why that that has not worked
so well in this context so
let me go back a little bit say sure the
scientists did not call for regulation
the cinema meeting was actually an
attempt to
bring out the various views from various
constituencies and to try to assess was
there or was there not a risk the
assessment was
there was some risk
but we could mitigate those risks by
having these guidelines right so the
guidelines were a recommendation of how
to proceed yeah now
if you look at some of the other
issues that have confronted science and
public policy
the one that
was came shortly thereafter was
genetically modified
right and the question was there's lots
of data that says it's safe yep and
there's lots of public policy that
doesn't want to have it in their
backyard what in the cilamar meeting
help
type meeting help to bring together
these two opposing views and try to
develop some kind of consensus right and
the answer that we found was they were
almost irreconcilable views and the
views on the opposition were mostly
cultural
they weren't science they weren't
questioning the scientific thing in
large part in large in the maine in
europe particularly it was the desire to
try to maintain the traditional type of
agriculture so we just never could get
the two sides
even on safety issues because i know
even the opponents often claim that
their safety problems right so the
companies set up trials they did all
kinds of the fda approved many of these
things after
examining the data
there was always a problem of
dissemination of weeds
weeds that would take over all of these
kinds of things arose
and
slowly but surely the scientific data
dispelled almost all of them
but never could challenge
people at the core values of their
culture
they felt about food what food meant to
them right and in many ways one of the
problems i think early on
and the ag business recognized it is
all the genetic modification they were
making were to facilitate better yields
for the farmers right make work easier
for the farmers
the public would say well what do i get
out of it i'm taking the risk of eating
something that you tell me is safe but
may turn out not to be safe in the long
run so why should i take that risk when
all it's doing is making a farmer's job
easier and
richer so is this a case maybe of the
scientific community not finding the
right way to explain or the right
message or the right well i'm not sure
what kind of message you could do
because it's we'll get to it
you could tell people that it would make
food less expensive for them or more
neutral all of those arguments were made
and they didn't they didn't work no and
i
my own view thought
ultimately the shopper is going to walk
into a market and see two bins and
there's the bin that was genetically
modified and there's the
wild type and the price is going to be
half for the genetically modified and
they're going to have to make a choice
yeah and they'll begin to the pocketbook
again will be free free markets
sometimes correct these things right
yeah now the issue of culture is the
same thing with the recom with the uh
stem cell issue yeah
so
we i don't know how many meetings when
the embryonic stem cell issue arose
there was the violent opposition coming
from
essentially the cultural right wing but
religious
organizations and then people who
themselves felt deeply about the
sanctity of life and
the anti-abortion
constituency so everything
as opposed to the recombinant to the
embryonic stem cell work
um
i don't know how many meetings i
attended where these two constituencies
tried to resolve their and it was like
talking by each other
talking right past each other you could
not persuade
those who
felt deeply
and conscientiously about
sanctity of life that you couldn't
convince them that this little
blastocyst
was not a definition of life and that's
it and that's not so well understood
when people want to say well let's have
a conference and bring these two
opposing views together yeah they have
to be views that are willing to listen
to each other yeah
and and that there's some
give and take as there was in the
recombinant dna and some of these other
things there is no middle ground well of
course with embryonic stem cells the
congress got into the act very quickly
in this case didn't they yes so you
testified i know in a number of hearings
in the senate yes were you in one of the
first ones
i was
i don't know in any girl like that right
yes
and
and what you you could see
what was being played out was this
cultural religious perspective against
the scientific opportunities yeah and
it was easy for that other side to poo
poo the scientific opportunities
and in fact say well you haven't done it
yet and you'd argue well we can't do it
yet because you won't allow us to do
it's the nature of research
i think if i look back on that whole
period
um
the scientific community coming together
at least in california
and being able to get embryonic stem
cell work approved
making the case to the public and
getting an almost overwhelming approval
um was another example where the
scientific community
used its
reputation for
and i i'm going to go back and say
syllabar set a tone
scientific learn to trust the scientists
my engagement in that public policy
debate wasn't as
rewarding as the
recombinant dna
because but but i'll tell you i'm going
to just admit to something which i have
admitted to a number of people during
that entire debate
i along with most of us
said
adult stem cells weren't ever going to
be useful
we have to rely on embryonic stem cells
and i think today
there's more work going on and more
interesting things going on with adults
themselves there's terrific work going
on with both with both right but i think
what i found is dismissing
the utility of adult stem cells when in
fact
more and more of them are being cultured
and propagated and maintained
and in terms of the debate about
embryo versus adult
i think
the most immediate benefits are going to
come out of either
adult
somatic
stem cells from various tissues
or from the
ips cells the cells that have been
where adults that cells have been
converted to embryonic embryonic-like
cells and i think
the debate was
good to have
and in the end i think we have progress
which was important there's good science
happening which is what really matters
right in all on all fronts yeah now
just to take the lesson syllabar one
step further
are there going to be other
problems that are going to arise well
this is what it's going to ask you i
mean you know looking forward
doesn't all new technology bring new
ethical challenges
more and more
a big one that's ongoing now is
synthetic biology okay
now you can make organisms make anything
and i have defended that and actually
been involved with thing and i'm a
strong advocate
but there are people saying yes but
and yes but is
what are the nasty things you can do
with the same technology
and i think we're going to have to work
through that so the government again has
set up a
a very strong panel to oversee the
developments of synthetic biology and
several interesting things have
developed so for example
these commercial places that'll make dna
for you
now have a rigorous protocol that they
have to examine
a request to make a particular dna
sequence
they have to translate it and see what
it in fact will
what kind of protein it will make
uh who's going to use it uh there's a
lot of things before they will actually
make it and trying to prove it so the
idea that some weirdo is going to send
in a request for some nasty small
but nevertheless synthetic biology
is confronting an issue of creating
microbes that will be making biofuels
yeah and i'm
absolutely astonished and amazed about
what people are actually doing
i mean craig venter is making whole
chromosomes yep jay
kiesling is
turning on organisms that are using
biomass
yeah the organism programmed to actually
digest cellulitis and xyloses
and convert them into sugar internally
and make
long-chain fatty sterify fatty acids
that are being used to drive trucks so
you so you sound very optimistic that we
can both solve the technical as well as
the safety concerns i think
the genome project has provided
an extraordinary library
of information of genes when you think
from not just humans but from all
organisms all organisms right so you can
go to an organism that sweet wormwood
plant yeah and take out three genes
and put them in e coli because they make
now artemisinin
what the heck is artemisinin artemisinin
is the major drug now being used for
treatment of drug malaria oh okay
and so it's a very complicated molecule
yeah and so it's costly to synthesize by
usual procedures
isolating it from the plant is very
complicated right so jay pulled out the
three g's to carry out the last three
steps of the synthesis of artemis and
engineered the steroid pathway of e coli
incredible so you make a precursor
and with the three enzymes from our from
the wormwood plant
they pour out artemisinin
and now big plant actually manufacturing
on a commercial scale so you can make an
anti-malaria drug in an e coli fermented
e coli fermented incredible okay and
that is now making
kerosene it's making
airplane fuels
so so in retrospect you
you took an enormous leap
when you
walked out of the lab and decided to
spend some time
working with the public
um is that a is that a good model going
forward do we need more of that do we
need less of it what are your what are
your thoughts about that well there are
people who can do this yeah
um who are articulate and
persuasive
and could play a role and there are
those that can't and won't
and i think we have to encourage
people because after all this is our
world the scientific community is and
what we do is is our world and if we
don't
defend it in one way explain it yeah
then we're not
doing half the job we publish papers
as a way of communicating what we've
done
but the general to each other doesn't
yeah the general public doesn't read
these papers and they're in the dark and
you're using mumbo jumbo to describe
what you're doing that's a different
thing so there
are people who are very skilled and
and enjoy
actually explaining what they do
in more general terms to the public
and that's a very valuable thing for
those people to do it
uh i think we have to
clear the path so it's not sacrificing
one's career
yeah i mean what if one were to make the
argument to some people they'd say well
you can only do it after you've gotten a
nobel prize which means it's a very
small population well okay it doesn't
have to be a nobel prize it could be
when your career has gelled to the point
where
you're now
recognized so that in fact if you're
going to make statements people will say
it's coming from some
authoritarian hate of sources build some
respect right younger people sometimes
say
um
i don't want to get involved in that i'm
in science to do science experiments
but when you grow up
okay and it is when you grow up and you
feel
assured of
a modicum of success
that you can go out and do this yeah
then you have to do it conscientiously
and seriously and honestly and you have
to bring rigorous science to what you do
thank you